What's the FIRST STEP to start a business?
So I got a great question from one of my YouTube viewers
(love you guys!)
from ThePolybagCollector, who wrote in to say
“If you want to start a business
what’s the first step you should take?
So this is a great question.
The most important first step
bar none is an easy question.
For those of you who are loyal subscribers of the channel
you already know what I’m going to say
you have to find your passion.
You have to build a business around something
that you are passionate about.
You have to be a little bit crazy
to be an entrepreneur because it’s going to be
really, really, really hard
and nobody really talks about how hard
it is to be an entrepreneur.
You just hear all the good things
and the big wins and the huge successes
but it’s really hard!
It’s going to be the hardest thing
you’ve ever done in your life
it’s starting a business and making it successful.
It’s that hard.
The same people, the logical people
the normal people
they’re going to quit because it gets too hard.
So you have to have a little bit of crazy in you
to be successful as an entrepreneur
and it’s that deep love
and passion for what you’re doing.
The things that you would do even if you weren’t getting any money
even if you’re not getting paid
saying, “I need to keep doing this because this is important.”
One of my favorite examples is George Lucas
who started Star Wars and Lucas Films
and Indiana Jones
and his first six years in business were a failure
complete failure – six years!
And his friends and his family said
“George, do the safe thing, get a job.
What are you doing?
This is not working.
Okay, one year, two years…
Six years?!
It’s not working, man. Stop!
You’re crazy.”
And what kept him going,
it wasn’t that he wanted to try to make a lot of money
it’s that he loved films.
And he said, “You know what?
I don’t care if I ever make money on this.
I have to find a way to keep going
because I love it so much.
That’s what kept him going.
That’s what you need to find to keep you going.
Lucas now is worth over 4 billion dollars.
He’s a multibillionaire.
But he only got there
it was never about the money for him
he got there because he loved what he was doing.
So the number 1 most important rule
how do you get started
find you passion.
Do something that you love and keep doing it every day.
Find something that you can’t live without doing.
You have to create this thing in the world because
it’s a part of you and you have to share it
and help other people achieve whatever their goals are.
That’s your first rule.
Believe.
For those of you watching, you liked the video
– thumbs-up below.
Let me know what you think.
Leave a comment below, ask me a question.
I’ll make a video response.
And click on my face if you want to subscribe to the channel
and see more videos like this.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.